welcome to this video boo carneiro okay
Scott gym but get that too often queen
bee three somebody can playing that bad
line that i forget i forget the
reputation come on probably you will
play a young and it's not like
completely completely rubbish queen bee
three but it's not good okay so here I'm
taking he'll play Bishop c4 to be 5 i'm
going to take and keep keep that pawn
yeah when 97 instead of Knight f6
because of that Bishop g5 pin that felt
felt a bit awkward so probably here this
is also a pin but I give f6 I think to
break it
so 94 even now as possible here yeah
that looks good now the f3 is under
pressure in p5 hangs so that should be
pretty good for black why is he doing
something crazy 9450 196 no so I think
chad is simple and probably not bad push
up to six maybe I'm going to keep
yourself let's push up on g3 does look
really weird
yeah I don't know does it try and form
the exchange sack with rupee one I think
I'm taking this the pieces that he has
simply not active enough need to round
up ground round up that's writer at porn
okay mmm that I should have considered a
little bit more carefully i think now
he's really having this somewhat
annoying porn rocky I tried to play
quickly and not get into some time
pressure him I didn't work out so well
and I think I should definitely play
King g7 getting out of yes yes but I
don't
f6 txt seven I don't get it I 55 check
check
white resigns yeah strange game yeah I
don't and here is this cream be three
line that I keep forgetting really how
it how it works it's not good for white
but I keep forgetting how it works okay
let's have that I think this is really
just a pawn down for what that this
cannot be any serious compensation he
has lost time with Bishop c5 we should
be five and the bishop is not even well
placed them no f6 must be you must be
good yeah here yeah you should try this
this is actually given by the engine yes
sir it's interesting I mean my queen IAM
check this is the line by but soft best
operation funny but if I feel like and
now if I take here he's actually when he
had looked his seven king is six route
27 wins Bishop c4 a while so I cannot
take so I have to go like here this is
like completely crazy this is the light
by the engine and black ass sir is one
porn up yeah white why he should have
done that really check yes it's more or
less more or less losing I think I was a
little bit to relax there with taking
the exchange allowing this is the spot
to come to f5 is not a really great idea
i had it does win but it looks a little
bit looks wrong to allow it this is also
not so
great maybe okay before we have too much
material already to to get into trouble
okay well thanks for watching